en fin de soirée lorsque nous avons
appris que son véhicule avait été vu
dans la rue la pension de famille des
charmilles nous avons fait ce porte à
porte chez tous les chez tous les
commerçants pour présenter la
photographie de ce personnage et c'est
le patron de l'hôtel de charme et qui
nous a dit qu'effectivement patrick
henry avait loué chez lui sont nombreux
mandats year une chambre depuis le 23
janvier
et nous sommes montés dans cette chambre
no entendu du bruit
patrick henry était là il a essayé de
fuir par le dans la terrasse parler de
toi mais les fonctionnaires qui détaille
le commissaire car il s'agit de reims
l'ont arrêté et non à mener dans la
chambre où vous avons découvert soulevé
le cadre du profil type d'accord est ce
que tout cela permet d'assurer qu'il
était seul cela ne permet pas d'être
assuré qu'il était seul seule
l'instruction l enquête complémentaire
nous continuons à faire dès ce soir ça
nous arrêtent et essaiera de les
terminer
je peux vous dire moi personnellement
que je pense qu'il n'était pas
accompagné
lorsque vous êtes entré dans la chambre
avec la police est ce que vous avez
remarqué quelque chose non
j'ai simplement vu les emballages de sac
le sac de couchage qu'il avait acheté
bleus en europe et l'enfant et moi je
suis ressorti aussitôt de la chance j'ai
ouvert parce que comme il s'était fermé
l'intérieur j'ai ouvert pour que les
policiers puissent rentrer avec le
individus en question est ce que ce que
vous connaissez de la chambre de ce que
vous avez vu permet de savoir quand et
où l'enfant mais ça c'est un avis tout à
fait personnel que je vous donne mon
avis
l'enfant n'a pas été tués ici qu'est ce
qui vous fait penser c'est juste au
dessus du burn entendu du bruit à
l'entente du marché ici on peut accéder
à ces chambres paris sans passer par le
bar et c'est au premier étage dans cette
chambre que se déroulait l'insoutenable
pendant 19 jours
l'enfant mort sans doute depuis le début
de la fère et patrick henry qui va et
vient dans la ville d'abord témoin et
puis suspect et puis de nouveau libre et
ce soir les soupçons l'arrestation l
écroulement atroce de tous les espoirs
patrick henry a donc loué une chambre
ici une semaine avant le rate
et puis un jour il est revenu il a suivi
ce chemin avec l'enfant quel jour on ne
sait pas encore les preuves de la
culpabilité sont accablantes
mais pour les circonstances on verra ce
qui est sûr tout a été préparé réfléchi
patrick henry à l'insu du logeur avaient
même changé le verrou de la chambre
comment at il pu qui est patrick henry
quand il est venu vous loué cette
chambre où l'avez vu vous avez parlé
avec lui oui comment est-il qui est cet
homme
ben c'est un monsieur qui m'a paru tout
à fait correct c'est un monsieur taille
moyenne long je veux dire au point de
vue du caractère apparent du
comportement est ce qu'il a l'air daf
pas du tout pas du tout pensé que même
après le geste qu'il a commis cette
atrocité vous pensez qu'il est fou ou
non d'après ce que vous avez vu de lui
le geste par l'union bourrel qualifié de
folie mais le monsieur n'est pas fou du
tout à mon avis il vous a paru équilibré
tout à fait tout à fait tout à fait